[Musique]
jean baptiste mourad zanni bonjour merci
d'être présent sur le plateau de tv 78
pour ce vip qui vous est consacré pour
plusieurs raisons la joie de vous avoir
tout d'abord vous êtes versaillais vous
travaillez à versailles vous êtes chef
vous êtes jeune chef étoilé première
étoile à 27 ans c'est très rare
et vous avez une actualité c'est à dire
qu'un livre sort sur vous voilà donc ça
va nous donner l'occasion de faire votre
connaissance
est ce que vous pouvez me raconter un
petit peu votre parcours professionnel
comment on en arrive là alors parcours
professionnel moi j'ai démarré tôt comme
beaucoup dans ce métier large démarré à
15 ans école hôtelière pendant quatre
ans donc j'ai fait ferrandi et ensuite
ensuite je partis travailler au trianon
palace à versailles sur les ordres de
simone zanoni très belles rencontres et
m'a vraiment pris sous son aile et m'a
fait faire le tour de la cuisine m'a
fait évoluer
vous avez fait plusieurs plusieurs
postes vraiment nourrit m'a fait me fait
énormément grandir après très bon jeu
parti à paris je pense très pour yannick
alleno au meurice en deux ans quand il
est parti je suis partie également du
meurice et je suis parti au liban
travailler pour lui je restais six mois
à beyrouth français ouais tout à fait à
son insu le stay humainement c'était
très intéressant culture très différente
terroir très différent et ça apporte
toujours son cynisme ans à l'étranger
mais des cars ensuite retour à paris
ouais je suis parti travailler aux
commerçants restaurants étoilés dans le
14e je travaillais pour philippe
bélissent en quelqu'un de super très
belle personne humaine manque officiel
je vous rencontre alors jusqu'à là je
pense que je pense que ça a joué dans
une carrière je pense
les rencontres surtout en ces métiers
sont des métiers difficiles si tu rends
compte hamas personne tu peux vite tant
dégoûté donc des métiers je pense que
oui d'accord c'est un sancerre
d'installer pardon est installé à
versailles à combien de temps il ya
trois ans et demi maintenant avec un
premier restaurant s'appelle qui
s'appelait donc la table du onze qu'on
avait installé rue saint-honoré au 11
rue saint-honoré tous les noms voilà et
donc tout fit gastronomie ans était
positionné sur une gastronomie abordable
en termes de prix je m'étais mis en tête
voilà qu'on joue et l'étoile mais je
m'étais mis trois quatre ans voilà et on
a eu la super surprise avec l'équipe qui
après nous ment on est une étoile
déjà alors un vous êtes très jeune j'ai
27 ans donc ça c'est rare pour avoir une
étoile et en plus cela vous l'avez eu
très vite apparemment ouais ouais c'est
vraiment là depuis l'ouverture c'est que
que du positif c'est sûrement génial
dans ce qu'on est en train de vivre une
aventure comme extraordinaire exilé en
france un chef étoilé d'en avoir 600 en
france je crois à peu près donc
c'est bien je suis hyper content c'est
très flatteur pour nous ça travailler
considérée alors on a eu de la presse
ont été remarqués donc c'est vraiment
très très flatté je suis très content de
le vivre avec
avec mes équipes votre équipe est ce que
je voulais qu'on dise aussi c'est que
vous êtes d'une famille de restaurateurs
moi tout à fait on est dans un milieu
moi j'ai grandi dans un restaurant mais
on a la grand-mère monte déjà soir à la
maison des bois à santa pauline entre
plaisir et pontchartrain est une vieille
auberge avec des jolis produits donc
j'ai toujours vu ça pour le moment des
cars et les seuls venir tout ça donc
j'ai des souvenirs quand même j'ai un
rapport à l'anr économique est d'accord
donc ce fameux fameux restaurant donc
dans le khat est saluée versailles ça a
tellement bien marché que qu'est ce qui
s'est passé alors du coup du coup du
coup les toilettes arrivé je pense que
la faire on le pousse à son maximum
et moi j'avais besoin quand même de
pouvoir voir ce qui allait se passer un
peu plus loin c'est à dire que voilà je
voulais qu'on ait plus de confort
j'ai envie de travailler pour la
deuxième étoile j'ai envie de travailler
pour le goût aux gens envie qu'on
remarquait on a envie d'avancer
donc une fois qu'on a une étoile on a
une pression particulière pour avoir
forcément la deuxième non non non on
pense la presse et des procédés choix
personnel après on n'est pas obligé de
se mettre de pression en moins c'est ce
que giteau moi je travaille pas pour le
michelin moment je travaille pour mes
clients je veux qu'il soit content c'est
la priorité
après c'est pour l'ego c'est important
pour les objectifs pour avancer pour
avancer confessionnellement on a besoin
de ça de se mettre en orbite chalenge
s'en est parti et du coup on a déménagé
le restaurant à vous êtes maintenant on
à la cour des senteurs sakho toujours à
versailles
c'était à côté du château on y est très
bien parce qu'on a beaucoup plus de ce
foyer donc l'amener à l'intérieur ça
fait comme étant vous êtes là ça fait
maintenant se faire un an et demi la
russe avant c'était le nôtre était allé
la voir les enseignants ont pas mal
changé dans le corps du chanteur mais je
pense que là il ya un équilibre qui
arrivait
certains n'avaient ni secret ouais voilà
de retour des métiers de bouche je
choque c'est un très bel endroit
vraiment c'est charmant c'est un écran
moi je suis vraiment très très bien car
absolument pas mes choix et du coup
alors on a installé le restauration amis
ici et dans la foulée on a ouvert aussi
une distro qui est rude satory voilà du
coup vous êtes quand même rester aussi
cat et saint louis avec un deuxième
établissement qui s'appelle du bistrot
du 11 alors que les concepts le concept
c'était un constable de bistronomie
c'est à dire que on et non entre deux
voiles ont fait pas de steak frites au
genre de choses on fait 1 montrent deux
c'est pas du gastro pur c'est pas du
bistrot plus abordables a plu à bord
d'un vol en a on a un menu à 37 euros
donc c'est ce qu'on voulait parce qu'en
fait c'est les cetc plafonné pour le
guide michelin il ya une distinction qui
s'appelle le bib gourmands ces plafonné
à ce tarif là voilà ça distingue d'un
rapport un bon rapport qualité prix et
nous c'était notre objectif et je suis
ravi parce qu'il arrivait la première
année et je suis très content
d'emplacements aussi la rupture il est
très vivant
et je pense qu'un établissement comme ça
ici c'est parfait kwh est donc c'est
complémentaire avec éclat caniveau je
veux qu une vraie cohérence entre entre
nos projets d'actes danse t'ouvrir pour
ouvrir aux questions d'argent
ok alors donc ce livre on va donc en
parler tout de même pas ce qui vous est
consacré alors on va jouer vous dire
tout de suite le les textes sont de
bruno ferret et les photos d'arnos pagny
voilà ça c'est dit et l'a préfacé de
notre ami alain marathon qui souligne
que c'est bien beau d'être chef mais
l'important c'est ce soit aussi les
producteurs
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi je
pense que si on n'a pas une jolie
matières premières n'ont pas pas ma
trace blanche pendant que nous ce roman
nous deux créneaux en plus soit pas je
pense pas qu'on ait une cuisine
compliqué on s'appuie sur des très beaux
produits
ça nous prend beaucoup de temps parce qu
on les sélectionne on va chercher les
producteurs tout ça mais justement
comment se diffère aussi parce que pour
avoir votre propre pas de votre propre
cuisine c'est dans le choix justement
des éléments que vous travaillez dont je
faisais le mans préau moi je considère
que a aujourd'hui j'ai 27 ans je
considère pas avoir mon style encore je
pense que tu avais pas votre pâte et
encore je pense que avoir trouvé sa
cuisine son style tout ça je pense que
je pense que ça prend du temps en temps
je pense que je pense en tout cas
aujourd'hui
je pense que j'ai trouvé mon créneau
j'ai trouvé ce qui me plaît
j'ai trouvé ce que j'aime faire at il
affirmé
moi j'aime beaucoup travailler le
végétal est tout seul mais en tout cas
je pense que ça prend un peu plus de
temps je peux pas affirmer aujourd'hui
que j'ai mon style j'ai ma patte
d'accord d'accord en tout cas je
j'essaie de cuisine alors justement le
végétal et plantes vous avez on en parle
dans ce livre qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est
ce qui vous plaît là dedans comment vous
vous les procurer comment vous
fonctionnez à ce niveau là aujourd'hui
l'on travaille avec
deux fournisseurs entre avec le potager
du roi qui est juste à côté avec j'ai un
très bel échange avec avec les
jardiniers de vrais passionnés de ski
font donc y cultive avec demande
exactement je peux leur dire par exemple
prévoit j'aimerais qu'on travaille ça et
ils le mettent sur le plan de culture
donc c'est intéressant entre avec
monsieur bastelica qui se trouvent dans
le sud ouest
question est ce monsieur est il fait que
des justement des plantes sauvages qui
nous livre à peu près de trois fois par
semaine et moi je voulais qu'il ya un
intérêt pas que parce que visuel parce
que des chefs qui met une herbe juste
parce que ça va être joli sur assiette
je veux qu'un autre intérêt que je vais
bien m'intégrer fiable qui en mangent
rien qui n'apportera rien aux plats moi
je vois aucun intérêt gustatif découvrir
et puis moi ça m'intéresse vraiment ça
m'intéresse vraiment parce qu'il ya
plein de bienfaits c'est bon pour la
santé c'est bon pour plein de choses
c'est très goûtu oui c'est une façon
d'aller vraiment vers le renouvellement
de la cuisine d'aller chercher des
aliments qu'on n'utilise pas d'habitude
vous avez des exemples je pensais à
l'épinette que c'est une vie note par
exemple ça se trouve sur le marché de
versailles voilà donc non mais je me
baladais puis en moi je vois jean
produits que je connais pas mais je
pense qu'il faut être curieux comme dans
tout métier mais je le mandant proches
et des tests qui viennent de votre
collaboration avec le monsieur du sud là
c'est quoi par exemple comme plante on
travaille bien on peut travailler les
oxalis la taz est un problème tout ça
personne ou très peu de personnes
connaissent des cas
et qui ont vraiment du goût qui apporte
un plat que boxer ça va porter de
l'acidité la taz est on en train de
faire un sorbet avec on a des arômes de
pêche c'est intéressant parce que ses
dégoûts qu'on ne connaît pas et du coup
on arrive à surprendre avec ça la
compagnie avec ça c'est très intéressant
et le côté visuel vous trouvez que c'est
que c'est très important qu'on en a
besoin mais non et puis plus c'est gros
c'est essentiel si j'ai le visuel je
pense car c'est essentiel c'est pas que
ça je pense que c'est pas la priorité je
pense que la priorité doit être sur le
goût mais quand un plat arrive sur ta
c'est le premier contact qu'on a avec
ces visuels
ça doit donner envie au moment d'aller
manger des yeux quoi ok et qu'est ce que
vous pensez de toutes ces émissions de
téléréalité sur la cuisine qui met ses
métiers très à la mode d'ailleurs ce que
ça donne une vraie image où vous trouvez
ça bien moi je trouve ça ça nous le
trancherons ça génial pour parce que
parce que le métier de cuisinier a été
pour pendant des années des dizaines
d'années dans longue c'était un métier
un peu plat car aujourd'hui voilà ça
revalorise ça met en lumière l'artisanat
et plein plein plein d'autres choses qui
étaient avec l'un d'eux valeur voilà
après c'est sûr que c'est pas la réalité
non ce n'est pas la réalité du métier
c'est bien plus dur que ce qui
paraissait les traders vous êtes électif
alors là moi je suis au passe sur la
gauche et à droite c'est
c'est un de mes chefs exécutifs qui
aient qui s'occupe du bistrot c'est
gabriel gras avec qui je travaille
depuis cinq ans au bistrot et gastro et
22 au total aidants et à la table à la
table on est 12 buts
donc j'ai deux collaborateurs qui
s'occupe des cuisines qui me lasser de
mes deux bras droit à bras gauche le
zerg arrive plus ces voix là gabriel
gras et stéphanie moquer ces deux
personnes vraiment qui m'épaule la
prochaine super équipe en mer d'ailleurs
l'intérêt de ce livre aussi c'est de
découvrir votre équipe
on voit l'intérieur des cuisines comment
vous fonctionnez les produits et c'est
ça qui était aussi intéressant parce que
c'est la face cachée
je pense moi je vois je voulais aussi
non ce qu'ils veulent je veux que ça
soit pas mon livre je voulais que ce
soit livre de l'équipe c'est pour ça que
je voulais qu'ils participent on a fait
des shootings le lundi est jour de
fermeture
je voulais qu'il soit en photo je
voulais qu'ils parlent moi je suis bien
conscient d'une chose c'est que en
cuisine qui fait rien tout seul
cuisinier dans un restaurant ça tourne
pas ce que parce qu'il ya une structure
parce que il ya des équipes qui sont
derrière qui pousse qui me suivent
après évidemment faux moteur mais là il
faut les sens se situe à l'école tous à
ccc petit s'est montrée dans ce très
beau livre les photos de son sublime
évidemment et écouter ça donne juste
envie de réserver 10 ans à l'avancé ça
pour aller 12 ans 12 ans 12 ans
maintenant on est passé à deux en ont
pris un coup de tant d'attention sur le
sur le dîner mais on a souvent dit à
petit se désister tout ne faut pas
hésiter à clé est arrivé au déjeuner
c'est un peu plus un peu plus court donc
d'accord ils ont noyé le bistrot bien
sûr il ya les masses trouve évidemment
aussi très bien jean baptiste mourad
zanni un grand merci non sur vous et
puis tu vas vite j'espère j'espère à
table alors merci
[Musique]
et